il faut s'intéresser de sauvegarde du
monarque a simplement parce qu'il est en
diminution dramatique qu'il a baissé de
plus de 90 % au cours des 20 dernières
années on a atteint un seuil où des
efforts de conservation sorte essentiel
des plaisirs de l'été c'est de voir la
nature évoluer sur sa terrasse dans son
jardin et malheureusement l'un des plus
beaux spécimens celui vous voyez
d'ailleurs actuellement le papier au
monarque est en voie de disparition mais
on vous parle d'une action citoyenne
pour les préserver on en discute avec
andry philippe drapeau picard qui est
coordonnateur du programme à l'espace
pour la vie
bonjour bonjour expliquez-nous comment
les citoyens peuvent s'impliquer et dans
le fond vous souhaiter que tous collecte
des données sur le monarque
oui exactement à l'insectarium d' espace
pour la vie on a un programme qui
s'appelle émission monarque dont je suis
coordonnateur
puis l'idée c'est de d'avoir dès que les
gens partagent leurs observations de
monarque puis d'asclépios avec nous donc
l'asclépiade si la plante hôte du
monarque c'est la seule plante sur
laquelle les monarques ont leurs yeux la
seule plante que les chenilles de
monarque mange donc on a besoin que le
cad pulmonaire finalement on a besoin de
savoir où cette lente leurs pouces puis
où le monarque qui l'utilisent pour
pouvoir protéger certains de ses
habitants
éventuellement on est assez simple on
demande aux gens de localiser dont la
leur jardin des papillons des oeufs des
chrysalides et de transmettre
l'information sur le site mission
monarque et je sais pas je crois qu'on
va voir leur vous le maître d'ailleurs
un bol notamment donc ce site est
honnête triple w pour un mission --et
monarque ch point org on voit d'ailleurs
actuellement
déjà l'an passé vous étiez venu nous
parler du projet alors quel genre
d'information vous avez déjà obtenu
bonne récolte oui ça fait le programme
est relativement jeune ça va être notre
troisième année c'est donner à vos biens
à chaque année notre nombre de
participants double puis en plus l'année
dernière puis cette année aussi on
savait que pour ça ça a été deux bonnes
années pour les monarques il y en a
beaucoup
donc ceci ça fait que c'est beaucoup
plus
plaisant pour les gens de participer
d'autant plus que en ce moment
aujourd'hui c'est le début du blitz
international de suivi du monarque qui
s'échelonne jusqu'au 4 ou puis ça c'est
un effort à l'échelle de l'amérique du
nord qui est organisée avec des
partenaires aux états unis au mexique
imite donc à partir d'aujourd'hui puis
pour toute la semaine on met les
bouchées doubles pour obtenir le plus de
données possibles sera encore le la
répartition puis l'abondance de
l'afrique a depuis ce monarque c'est à
dire qu'on vient en appui
ils sont où à ce moment de l'année c'est
quelque chose qu'on veut reproduire
année après année pour avoir une photo
instantanée
donc on peut comparer pour voir qu'est
ce qui se passe avec eux en été et je
rebondis sur ce que vous venez de dire
d'ailleurs service donc le canada
évidemment cette action citoyenne ici
les états unis le mexique parce que le
monarque faut quand même le dire
parcours à chaque année à chaque année
4000 kilomètres pour migrer du sud du
canada jusqu'au mexique
oui effectivement il pense pas l'hiver
avec nous c'est trop fort pour lui on le
comprend donc à la fin de l'été au début
de l'automne
ll nous quitte pour aller au mexique
puis rien en été donc c'est la même
population qui qui traverse le continent
finalement donc si on veut protéger
cette population là bas on a besoin de
travailler ensemble
peu importe les frontières pour mais
pouvoir voilà pour le protéger puis pour
s'assurer qu'ils continuent à le voir
migrer dans le futur
très bien alors ça se passe on le redit
du 27 juillet au 4 août ça s'appelle le
blitz et on peut aussi se rendre sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le mot-clé blitz
monarque merci beaucoup monsieur drapeau
picarda boîtier avec moi merci à vous
gardez l'oeil ouvert puis partagez vos
observations avec mais cela n'a
absolument